deswegen beginnen wir nun diesen festakt
mit der übernahme des felt zeichens
oberstleutnant eric graf übernehmen da
die musik leeren zug stabskompanie auf
mein kommando
ich spreche sie an als das ganze das
ganze acht ehrenzug presse wird zum
einmarsch des filzens das ganze rechts
feldzeichen einmarschieren
[Musik]
das ganze hier in zug die ja das ganze
parade in kürze erfolgt nun das
ankündigungs signal und die meldung an
den militärisch höchsten lesung der
militärkommandant von niederösterreich
brigadier martin jaworek im anschluss
hören wir die bundeshymne gefolgt vom
abschreiten der front unter den klängen
des präsentiermarsch es um zum abschluss
die große flaggenparade
[Musik]
der entzug präsentiert zur meldung an
der militärkommandant das ganze rechts
herr brinker tier oberstleutnant kraft
meldet das feldzeichen des aufklärungs
und artilleriebataillon 3 die fahne des
österreichischen kameradschaftsbundes
stadtverband mistelbach die gardemusik
den ehrenzug gestellt durch die
stabskompanie a3 sowie die rekruten des
instruments juli zur feierlichen
angelobung in der kaserne angetreten
ja wohl angelogen durch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ganze hat ihren zug gebe ja das
ganze
parallel wird das ganze nacht ihren zug
presse flagge wissen dass ganze
rechtsschutz
[Musik]
das ganze er hinzu wer das ganze parade
ist folgen nun die grußworte des
bataillons kommandanten der kaserne
mistelbach oberst hans peter hohlweg und
danach spielt uns die gardemusik einen
choral
meine rekruten sie sät fünfter juli
diesen jahres hier in die wolke aus
kasernen mistelbach erhöht und horn
umfasst die ihre basis ausbildung
erfolgreich abgeschlossen
das freut nicht als bataillonskommandant
und das freut mich umso mehr dass sie in
wenigen minuten das treuegelöbnis auf
die republik österreich sprechen werden
und wir alle sind gekommen ihnen zu
ehren
es gibt heute eine ehrenformation wir
einen ehrenzug wir haben die gardemusik
wen wir haben zwei fahnen trupps von
kameradschaftsbund und die standarte des
aufklärungs und artilleriebataillons
drei hier antreten lassen wir haben zwei
waffengattungen man sieht auch hinter
mehr als aufklärer haben wir diese
radfahrzeuge iveco wo wir uns jetzt im
auslandseinsatz befinden und wo wir auch
grenzschutz im südburgenland hier
durchführen und die artillerie batterie
der war diese woche auch scharf schießen
auf eine entfernung von 15 bis 20
kilometer dass man das auch hier
vorstellen kann
es sind auch viele ehrengäste der
einladung gefolgt und ich darf jetzt
diese auch begrüßen
an der spitze zwei herren von der
politik in vertretung von
landeshauptfrau mitglied nationalrats
abgeraten andreas bin ich und wenn dazu
hackten christian lösch von der fpö
herzlich willkommen
zwei unmittelbare vorgesetzte von mir
dann wahrscheinlich weiter genau auf die
finger schauen
ich begrüße den militärkommandanten von
niederösterreich sprecher der martina
beck und der stellvertretenden
kommandanten der treten jägerbrigade
oberst franz lang dollar geschätzte
erste aus rücksicht unserer rekruten
bietet das setzen der applaus etwas
sparen denn ihr hintern zu halten und am
ende einen kräftigen applaus dann hier
spenden
ich begrüße für die hässlichkeit von der
römisch katholischen kirche militärdekan
alfred weidlich und von der
evangelischen kirche militärsektor
roland lang von der
bezirkshauptmannschaft mistelbach herr
magister robert kromm und die amtsärztin
frau doktor sabine ullrich von der
garnisonsstadt mistelbach denn hier ein
vize bürgermeister manfred restloch die
stadträte in google andrea und die
gemeinderäten lieblinge elke größere
flächen direktor der
landwirtschaftskammer niederösterreich
dessen sohn hier angetreten ist diplom
ingenieur franz raab und der
bezirksstellenleiter der
wirtschaftskammer magister klaus habe
jetzt gar vor kurzem war sie noch in
monaco heute mistelbach ist ziemlich
gleicher ebene
sie bringen auch den hochadel die
kaserne mittelbar sie ist auch die
gottesmutter der kaserne mistelbach ich
begrüße härter und standort augsburg von
lothringen
ich begrüße von der vertretung viel zu
nett
gerhard die sicherheits familie des
bezirkes mistelbach ist hier vollzählig
vertreten begrüßte der
bezirkspolizeikommandant oberst florian
laden gruber von der feuerwehr
der bezirksbeirat nord fernseher hat
markus schuster kommandanten
stadtkommandanten kommissar anwärter
klaus neubauer und vom roten kreuz ins
gehege kämen kamerateams bund ist mit
einer fahne jeder treten begrüße vom
land magister wolfgang heuer haupt
bezirksobmann wird soll den kreis als
bezirksobmann johann lehner und den
stadtkommandanten weiter ofenauer
zweierpartner dass ich eine mistelbach
stoß sodass er am schnellsten wachsende
mobilfunkanbieter österreichs und der
hat sich aus meiner sicht der
militärisch besten partner hier
ausgesuchte kaserne
ich begrüße den geschäftsführer mit
garten franz und andrea bücher von der
bawag psk begrüße ich herzlich
vermutlich manfred schneider brigitte
und frust nicht annemarie die gardemusik
mit einem ensemble recht herzlich hier
willkommen vor den medien habe ich bis
jetzt die herbert michaela gesehen und
natürlich zu guter letzt darf ich auch
alle angehörigen hier begrüßen ich hoffe
sie hatten einen kurzen einblick in die
kaserne
es ist wohl der grund hat gesagt das ist
die erste richtige angelobung in
niederösterreich seit über einem jahr
auf klarem blick für höheren ebene
darüber es ist die erste angelobung des
bundes jahreszeit märz 2020 wo wir
wieder mit angehörigen mit ihnen hier
eine angelobung fern dürfen das war mir
hier ganz besonders
wichtig ist auch die ihre freunde
bekannte verwandte jährigen freundinnen
die mittels livestream hier zugeschaltet
sind einige gesagt das ist schade dass
man nur zwei personen mitnehmen darf ein
anderer weg gut dessen namen ich jetzt
nicht vertreten hat gesagt zwei
freundinnen und durch sehr besser wenn
die getrennt voneinander hier zu sehen
und ich glaube wie alle jetzt können
unsere rekruten einen kräftigen applaus
spenden
[Applaus]
vielen dank im namen der gruppen den
applaus haben sie sich wirklich verdient
bis jetzt waren sie fast bei allen
überprüfungen und tests positiv aus bei
zwei waren sie negativ das wissen sie am
besten positiv waren
sie haben ihre schießausbildung positiv
durchgeführt die schießübungen die
scheiben zerschossen der neuen anlage
diese woche sie haben auch hier den
wachdienst ersten überprüfung gehabt
ebenfalls positiv das freut mich
negativ waren sie beim suchtgift test
auch das ist erfreulich und wir führen
ja dreimal in der woche auch einen test
durch unter was ich bis jetzt auch
durchgehend negativ was mich besonders
freut ist dass bereits über 60 prozent
von ihnen krone kämpft sind das ist in
ihrer generation eine hohe impfrate kann
nur sagen meine damen und herren eine
hohe impfbereitschaft erhöhte
einsatzbereitschaft des bundesheeres und
auch ihre sicherheit von einem
alkoholtest habe ich wollte sehen
noch nämlich gehört habe dass 70%
gestern in der sommerserie in mistelbach
waren es brauchen wir jetzt hier nicht
wissen
sie sind an der dritten liga private
ungefähr ein drittel kommt dann in
einigen tagen nächste woche dann in die
kaserne straße südsteiermark ein drittel
ungefähr dass ich eine mautern und andré
wo bleibt hier einige kommen dann noch
hier in anderen kasernen
ich darf ihnen jetzt bereits auch alles
erdenklich gute wünschen beim bundesheer
bin froh dass er sich für den wehrdienst
hier entschieden haben
ich wünsche ihnen eine gute zeit beim
bundesheer eine schöne angelobung leute
mögen meine nachredner heute sich kurz
halten und meine und rekruten vielen
dank
alles gute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der choral hat bereits angekündigt es
folgende worte der militärischen
geistlichkeit für die evangelische
kirche militär rektor roland wenn um
sozusagen auf der abschiedstournee für
die römisch-katholische kirche
militärdekan alfred weidlich
im anschluss daran spielt wir uns die
gardemusik denn jaworek marsch ein
herzliches grüß gott seitens meines
übergewicht kameraden und von mir allen
an zu geloben rekruten ein fest und
ehrengästen und allen die im dienst des
österreichischen bundesheeres stehen und
hier gegenwärtig sind interessant heute
eine ökumenische heilige fast der die
katholische kirche gedenkt ich habe es
dem evangelischen kameraden gesagt wir
feiern heute die ergebnisse oder
birgitta von schweden die eine sehr
fromme frau war und der mann früh
verstorben ist und die dann ihr leben in
den dienst der nächstenliebe gestellt
hat und sie wurde bestattet in einer
kirche die heute den evangelischen
christen gehört und von den
evangelischen marienschwestern betreut
wird aber so viel nur am rande
ich lasse mich gerne bei meinen kurzen
worten von den lesungen des kommenden
sonntags leiten
und da ich geschaut was ist denn am
kommenden sonntag übermorgen so in der
lese ordnung zu finden ich habe gefunden
einen brief des apostels paulus an die
gemeinde in ephesus und dort schreibt er
etwas was glaube ich sehr leicht auf
unseren soldatischen dienst übertragen
werden kann
leiterin ich ermahne euch ein leben zu
führen das des rufes würdig ist der an
euch der ging
wir haben gehört ihr habt euch gemeldet
für den dienst beim heer
ich bin da immer ein bisschen skeptisch
ich sage ihr seid da ob mit großer
begeisterung oder weniger großer
begeisterung aber auf alle fälle bei
sich ihr seid aus treue da und ihr seid
dem ruf gefolgt denn die österreichische
bevölkerung schon vor jahren an euch
gerichtet hat ja wir wollen dass unsere
junge männer den wehrdienst die
wehrpflicht erfüllen
es ist ein ruf der an euch ergangen ist
erweist sich dieses rufes würdig in
allen passiert aber jetzt hier seit dem
mord an zeit in straße und der brüssel
scheint noch weiter seitdem übt
friedfertig und geduldig das habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch schon in der zeit
der ausbildung gebraucht
viele werden die da auf den boden
zurückgeholt durch die anforderungen
deren einen gestellt werden
ja da lernst du demut dann lernst du
auch geduld ertrags einander in liebe
ist die basis die kameradschaft haltet
dieses band fest es ist die basis für
gut erfüllte auftrage halte zusammen bei
allen wassern euch anforderungen
herangetragen wird und bewahrt die
einheit durch das band des friedens und
dann sind wir auch dort wo zu uns der
kommandant heute besonders eingeladen
hat nämlich zum gedenken 30 jahre
sicherungseinsatz zu jugoslawien
wir wissen dass wir soldatinnen und
soldaten des österreichischen
bundesheeres auch eingesetzt werden in
grenzen
ein satz dass wir eingesetzt werden
jetzt im zusammenhang mit der bahn zu
bestimmten aufgaben jetzt ist das
hochwasser dazu gekommen aber vor allem
natürlich der blick 30 jahre
sicherungseinsatz die leute zählen auf
uns zählen auf euch was auch immer auf
euch zukommt müsst und dürfte das wissen
allerdings bei alldem begleitet der der
den menschen im letzten ruft nicht der
militärkommandant nicht die behörden die
für rekrutierung und einführung funk
zuständig sind sondern zu eurem leben
berufsrichter eine unser herr und der
möge euch begleiten und möge auch alte
opfer vergelten die in den 30er an
sicherheitseinsatz die kameradinnen und
kameraden geleistet wurden
er wehrte er an und festgäste liebe
angehörige und familien fallen liebe
rekruten
ich habe heute einen vers aus dem
römerbrief mitgebracht wo es heißt lass
dich nicht vom bösen überwinden sondern
überwinde das böse mit gutem
böses mit guten überwinden ist mehr als
eine frage der vernunft und der klugheit
ich denke da auch an den satz aus dem
alten testament auge um auge zahn um
zahn barbarisch und blutrünstig klingt
das und wird leider auch immer wieder
mit soldaten mit dem hier in verbindung
gebracht
von einer vorbereitung habe ich auch
daran gedacht wir feiern oder gedenken
30 jahre sicherungseinsatz zu
jugoslawien
ja ist denn das nicht genau dieses
blutrünstige dieser kubanische einsatz
nein damals falls sicherlich hier war
damals noch nicht auf der welt ich
leider schon und wie sagen voll hier
alle damals die fernsehbilder gesehen
haben und wir dankbar wir waren das an
der grenze soldaten unseres heeres
standen um uns als österreicherinnen und
österreicher zu sichern und auch
flüchtlinge und opfer zu empfangen
lass dich nicht vom bösen überwinden
sondern überwinde das böse mit gutem
überwinden dieses wort ruft
vielfältigste widersprüchliche
assoziationen hervor
gehörst könnte dazu verleiten eine
moralpredigt zu halten
pfarrer neigen manchmal vielleicht dazu
auf der einen seite das gute auf der
anderen seite das böse und das böse muss
bekämpft und biss
werden aber was ist das böse oder wer
ist böse was er laut uns in verbindungen
mit menschen
diese unterscheidungen zu treffen
unsere wahrnehmungen unser oft so viel
bares einschätzungsvermögen was kann mir
dabei helfen das gute wirksam werden zu
lassen wenn ich den bösen mit dem bösen
konfrontiert bin ein evangelischer
theologe weiter dazu und dass sie die
lösung wohl finden könnten wenn wir die
antwort auf drei fragen finden was ist
die wichtigste zeit in meinem leben
welcher mensch ist der wichtigste im
leben des einzelnen und welches werk ist
das wichtigste im leben
wenn ich meine erfahrung auch die
richtigen antworten
es gibt nur eine wichtigste zeit in
unserem leben den augenblick die
gegenwart ohne dass wir vergangenes
vergesse aber zukünftiges außer acht
lassen
aber der augenblick ist darum die
wichtigste zeit weil wir nur diese zeit
in der hand haben und beherrschen können
der wichtigste mensch ist der mit dem du
im augenblick zusammen hier mit einem
kameraden hier wir als ehrengäste da
niemand kann wissen ob er je wieder mit
ihr mit ihm zusammen kommen und das
wichtigste werk ist ihr und ihm gutes zu
tun
denn darum ist der mensch von gott in
die welt gesandt
so lade ich euch ein geht in euren
dienst als rekruten vorgesetzte und
nimmt es mit in ihre familien und ich
meine dann kann das wunder geschehen
dass ein jeder
ein jeder genug anfliegen glück hat das
werden wir unsere im leben doch so
dringend brauchen
[Musik]
es folgt nun die ansprache des
militärkommandanten von niederösterreich
brigadier martin jaworek und im
anschluss daran hören wir das musikstück
stolz auf niederösterreich
vorerst danke da gar die musikvereine
mache das für meinen kapellmeister
erstaunen dass man das auch mit weniger
als 50 musiker spielen kann
geschätzter die abgeordneter in
vertretung unserer landeshauptfrau die
letzte abgeordneter ich danke euch für
euer kommen bei gerade wenn vertreter
des parlaments sie herauskommen
eine angelobung mit uns feiern das ist
ein ganz klares zeichen dass die politik
zur österreichischen bundesheer steht
geschätzter herr bezirkshauptmann
stellvertreter geschätzter herr
vizebürgermeister werte ehrengäste
geschätzter kommen stellte kommandant
arithnea brigade geschätzte damen und
herren aber vor allem die schätzte
kameraden des eintretens termines juli
20 21 des aufklärungsbataillons 34
mistelbach sie werden kürzer als
soldaten republik österreich feierlich
angelobt
aber es würde heute schon angesprochen
durch ko mit 19 ist alles anders
obwohl diese kaserne wie sie sehen
können sie in einem sehr guten zustand
befindet laufend vor allem versorgungs
mäßige selbstständigkeit wie die neuer
tankanlage vor einigen jahren erweitert
wird
wir legen auch sehr viel wert auf ihr
moderne unterkünfte ist es doch etwas
anderes
die chefs der herr vizebürgermeister ich
sage dir ich würde heute gerne so wie
früher in den anderen orten hier werden
lieber am hauptplatz stehen aber es ist
noch nicht so weit
der südliche bundeswehr führt in
niederösterreich in etwa 16 an gelungen
im jahr durch ziel ist es mit diesen
öffentlich sehr wirksame veranstaltungen
das gesamte bundesland gleichmäßig
abzudecken
aufgrund der hohen integration das
wirklich bundeswehr in die gesellschaft
was wir heute wieder hier eindrucksvoll
sehen erhalten wir natürlich bei weitem
mehr angebote als wir abdecken können
und das besonders hier im weinviertel
ich darf ja auch um verständnis
versuchen dass wir nicht alle wünsche
immer zum gewünschten termin durchführen
können aber ich glaube wir sind
gemeinsam am richtigen weg dass er
wieder hinaus in die ortschaft und
städte gehen können wie sich geschätzte
gäste aus der einladung entnommen haben
gedenken wir heute oder dieses jahr dem
einsatz vor 30 jahren und 30 jahre sogar
so lange her des militärischen sich
großeinsatz an unserer grenze und sie
haben viele der herren die sich hier
bereits im fortgesetzten alter befinden
waren damals auch junge soldaten und
haben daran teilgenommen
ich kann mich noch erinnern ich war
damals oberleutnant wie schnell die zeit
vergeht
damals waren mit jeder der staatsgrenze
im einsatz zum schutz der souveränität
österreichs konkret um ein übergreifen
der kampfhandlungen auf unserer
staatsgebiet zu verhindern und die
bevölkerung zu schützen
dies entspricht genau der hauptaufgabe
der militärischen landesverteidigung
sowie sie unsere verfassung vorgibt
details geschätzte kameraden dem auftrag
ihres patrons quanten folgend können sie
dementsprechend nachlesen ich möchte
hier nicht ins detail gehen aber
geschätzte rekruten sie werden im rahmen
ihres kontaktes genau auf diese aufgabe
vorbereitet und genauso wie diese
aufgabe benötigen sie die waffe die sie
den händen halten und sie brauchen
dementsprechend der militärische
ausrüstung wie sie zum beispiel rechts
und links von mir
dahinter steht ich möchte aber gerade
wenn ich in mistelbach bringt dieser
kann es um die aufgaben sprechen die
restliche bundesheer seit nahezu
eineinhalb jahren durchführt und zwar im
assistenzeinsatz für die
gesundheitsbehörde
und so wie es voriges jahr eine relativ
lange zeit war im assistenzeinsatz für
die polizei die sehr große bandbreite
umfasst
ich meine hier nur das kontakt racing
der dienst gemeinsam mit dem roten kreuz
beim treffen die im logistik die
pädagogen bei der u bahnen testungen die
massen festungen und auch die
schwergewichts kontrolle mit der polizei
und gesundheitsbehörden der grenze ich
werde damen und herren die finden auch
weiterhin stadt genau zu dem zeitpunkt
wo jetzt spreche finden im weinviertel
kontrollen statt am grenzübergang
hohenau und am grenzübergang lahr
gemeinsam mit der polizei das ist auch
der grund warum ich diese rot weiß rote
schleife tragen weil ich einsatzführer
der kommandant in niederösterreich wien
das auch geschafft hat ari vatanen und
drei fabrikaten schnelle kräfte war
immer bereit und hat alle aufgaben dass
der letzten eineinhalb jahre ohne wenn
und aber auch erfüllt ich möchte mich
hier beim auf gesamtrang drei
bei allen von ihnen einige die ich hier
sehe haben gemeinsam mit mehr gedient
einfach bedanken eine tadellose leistung
ebenfalls haben diese einsätze sowie
alle einsätze zusätzlichen bundesheeres
bis dato klage zeigt dass und mit
unseren kameraden damit es nicht geht
ich schätze die kameraden
sie wurden bereits sie werden bereits
eingewiesen welche vorteile und welchen
mehrwert sie für sie persönlich ein
dienst der miliz hat das östliche
bundesheer ist und auch im einsatz und
zwar in ergänzung der kameraden der
freiwilligen feuerwehr in hinblick auf
da die regen und hochwasser katastrophen
sei es in schattenberg dieser einsatz
ist bereits abgeschlossen aber derzeit
findet hier in niederösterreich gerade
an einsatz statt in weißenkirchen wo
verklausungen an der donau
dementsprechend entfernt werden
zusätzliche bundeswehr ist immer auch
mit diese einsätze verfügbar
aber natürlich nicht in konkurrenz zu
anderen einsatzorganisationen schon
immer dann wenn es die behörde
dementsprechende anfordert doch nun
zurück zu ihnen geschätzte angetretene
kameraden
sie haben sich entschieden im notfall
unsere heimat die republik österreich
mit der waffe zu verteidigen
sie sind bereit dafür das höchste gut
das sie haben ihr leben einzusetzen
ich gratulieren dass wir die der
comandante respekt vor diesem entschluss
sie können das nämlich deshalb mit einem
guten gewissen tun das in einem heer
dienen welche sich wie sich werten wie
verantwortung schutz der demokratie
achtung der menschenrechte sowie frieden
und souveränität verschrieben hat der
einsatz mit der waffe ist die
kernkompetenz und um ein neues modernes
wort zu gebrauchen das
alleinstellungsmerkmal des touristischen
bundesheeres geschätzte angehörige wenn
sie hier die reihen der rekruten blicken
und wenn sie daran denken dass die kern
rekruten die eigentlich erst einige
wochen bei uns
ich möchte ihnen hier vor ihren
angehörigen gratulieren zur tadellosen
haltung trotz der hitze und in dieser
disziplin dürfen
ich darf man auch gesagt lieber drei
oder die bewährten führung von oberst
hans peter hohlweg würde für eine
organisation aber auch für den mut diese
feier hier diese feier hier
dementsprechend zu gestalten
geschätzte rekruten
ich fordere sie auch weiterhin gemeinsam
ihre ausbildung mit ihren ausbildern und
kommandanten mit große land fortzusetzen
werden sie marken botschafter des
russischen bundesheeres ein auf
volkswagen österreich vielleicht findet
auch einige von ihnen ihre zukunft
ermöglichen bundeswehr
ich wünsche ihnen ein unfallfreier
abschluss ihres dienstes geschätzte
damen und herren werte angehörige
ich möchte mich auch abschlüsse als
staatsbürger familienvater mit einer
suchen anzuwenden
lassen sie sich impfen denn es geht
nicht um sie selbst
und es geht auch nicht darum ob sie
schnell eine disco besuchen dürfen
sondern es geht darum dass die
gesellschaft dieses virus unter
kontrolle bringt nachdem ich gehört habe
dass einige kameraden nach straße
verlegen nach der grundausbildung liebe
ich ihnen auch noch mit dass die durch
das niederschreiben botschaft ab bitte
nehmen sie ausreichend bei twitter bac
mit es lägen das österreichische
bundesheer das leben unserer republik
österreich in einem freien und geeinten
europa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es spricht nun in vertretung der
landeshauptfrau von niederösterreich der
abgeordnete zum nationalrat andreas
münch
hohe geistlichkeit geschätzte
militärkommandanten werte ehrengäste und
festgäste liebe familienangehörige sehr
geehrte regener mit dem heutigen
gelöbnis mit ihrer bereitschaft den
wehrdienst beim österreichischen
bundesheer zu absolvieren
geht ihr eine große persönliche
veränderungen viele neuen gegebenheiten
neue herausforderungen und ein neues
gemeinschaftsgefühl
er geht aber nicht nur einen großen
persönlichen schritt sondern auch einen
sehr wichtigen schritt für uns als
gesellschaft
er kommt aus unterschiedlichsten schulen
und aus unterschiedlichsten berufen und
dient jetzt gemeinschaft gemeinsam für
unsere republik österreich das
österreichische bundesheer ist unsere
sicherheitsgarantie unsere versicherungs
polizei und die ihr seid jetzt ein ganz
wichtiger teil davon
die herausforderungen für unser heer
werden nicht weniger ganz im gegenteil
der kommandant hatte schon gesagt die
aufgaben werden immer vielseitiger und
es stellen sich völlig neue
herausforderungen
denken wir an die flüchtlingskrise 2015
den terroranschlag im letzten jahr die
immer häufiger auftretenden wetter
extreme mit hochwasser und vermurungen
oder die vielen internationalen einsätze
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten nehmen
wir die letzten eineinhalb jahre der
korona pandemie oder gehen wir etwas
weiter zurück und denken an die
jugoslawien krise und dem sicheren
sicherungseinsatz an der staatsgrenze zu
slowenien dessen dreißigsten jahrestag
wir heute hier gedenken wir sehen die
herausforderungen sind äußerst viel
fertig und jeder dieser situation wirkt
sich unmittelbar auf uns alle aus unser
heer unsere soldatinnen und soldaten ihr
seid da wenn not am mann ist und hilfe
dringend benötigt wird von seiten der
politik ist es mir wichtig hier ein ganz
großes danke für ihren einsatz und ihr
engagement für die republik österreich
auszusprechen
ich bedanke mich auch hier ganz
besonders
oberst hans peter hohlweg dem
kommandanten der kaserne hier dass er
heute nach so langer zeit hier wieder
eine angelobung durchgeführt hat ich
bedanke mich aber auch bei
militärkommandant brigadier martin
jaworek für alles bisher in dieser
schwierigen zeit geleistet
es war keine einfache zeit durch
militärkommandant hast gerade aufgezählt
wie vielschichtig und wie viele einsätze
und wo gerade unsere soldaten im einsatz
sind gerade in schwierigen zeiten ist
ein gutes miteinander zwischen politik
und bundesheer möglichst und ohne
reibungslos besonders wichtig sie sind
nun teil dieses miteinander
in diesem sinne darf ich die besten
grüße unserer landeshaupt vor johanna
mikl-leitner aussprechen und ihnen ihre
hübsche mitgeben helfen wo andere nicht
mehr können ist ein leitspruch den unser
bundesheer mit stolz nach außen trägt
dieses motto ist weniger eine
eigenwerbung
des bundesheeres sondern das was in der
bevölkerung ankommt und so sehr
geschätzt wird
genau das sieht man in euch in unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten
ich wünsche ihnen allen viel
soldatenglück alles gute und auch das
darf nicht zu kurz kommen viel freude
und schöne erinnerungen an euren dienst
beim österreichischen bundesheer hier in
mistelbach straßenmaut es lebe das
österreichische bundesheer es lebe
unsere republik österreich
es lebe unser gemeinsames friedliches
europa dankeschön
meine geschätzten damen und herren sehr
geehrte festgäste liebe rekruten wir
kommen nun zum eigentlichen höhepunkt
des heutigen festaktes es wird in kürze
das feldzeichen vortreten und auch zwei
ausgewählte grundwehrdiener die das
treuegelöbnis direkt am feld zeichen
ablegen werden es ist es christian
strache aus basdorf und florian haas
staaten durch das ganze macht
feldzeichen vortreten
[Musik]
eingeteilt rekruten vortreten
rekruten zum regenten sprecht mir nach
ich gelobe mein vaterland die republik
österreich und sein volk zu schützen und
mit der waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe den gesetzen und den
gesetzmäßigen behörden treue und
gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
und mit allen meinen kräften der
republik österreich
und dem österreichischen volk zu dienen
rekruten vom eingestellten fluten
eintreten
vertreten
[Musik]
es erfolgt nur das abstellen der
niederösterreichischen landes und im
anschluss daran dass er bitten um
weitere befehle das ganze parade
das ganze paket zum presse zur
niederösterreichischen landesgrenze
rechts
[Musik]
das ganze hat ihre zug die wer das ganze
paradeboot das ganze karriere zu pressen
wird
zur meldung an der militärkommandant das
ganze rechts
die wasserkraft meldet die beendigung
der feierlichen angelobung und bittet um
weitere beispiele der wohl abbrechen
weil direkt melden
ganze ihre zug gewehr ab das ganze
gerade lud der militärkommandant hat den
befehl erteilt abzurücken
zuvor wird noch das feldzeichen aus
marschieren bevor auch die hier
angelobten grundwehrdiener aus
marschieren
das ganze sagt dazu presse wird zum
ausmaß des felsens das ganze rechts
fällt sicher aus marschieren
[Musik]
das ganze leben zu geben
das ganze blut und ehre zukommt
stabskompanie kommando übernehmen
ins wochenende abtreten lassen meine
geschätzten damen und herren dies
behindert den offiziellen festakt die
soldaten werden hierzu in kürze aus
marschieren dann abtreten die waffen
versorgen haben dann ein langes
wochenende